motif is an online broker with a twist
we don't want you to buy individual
stocks and securities because it doesn't
work instead we want you to invest
conceptually we want you to invest in
ideas it could be an interesting
technology trend like robotics it could
be a trading strategy that buys the most
beaten-down stocks every week
automatically in rebalances or it could
be an Ivy League endowment model that
just sits there and manages itself over
time we take these ideas and allow you
to act on them by turning them into what
we call a motif and a motif very simply
is a intelligently weighted basket of
stocks up to 30 stocks built around one
of these ideas and you can purchase a
motif in one click for the cost of a
single stock transaction 995 to buy 30
stocks in real time and you can buy a
motif that we built or you can buy a
motif that our community but has built
it took us about a year to build 120 of
these motifs it took our customers our
community less than six months to build
35,000 of these motifs they're actually
more motifs then there are mutual funds
and ETFs in the United States you can
think of a motif as a lens into the
markets do women make better CEOs and
men they're better does it pay to be gay
there's a motif there too these ideas
are around us all the time and it's
about taking the notion of investing and
making it easy whether we're a newbie
investor or a sophisticated investor we
all think conceptually and we believe
you should invest conceptually when you
find a motif that you like let's pick a
motif that's trending well right now
like modern warfare when you click on
the motif we give you a very simple
blurb of what the motif thesis is and
you hover over here you can see how the
individual stocks have done if you click
on performance you get to play around
with the performance see how this motif
has done in different time periods you
can type in a equivalent benchmark of
fund or an ETF and you can see how this
motif has done one of the reason this
motif typically outperforms benchmark
index is because we have zero fees and
when you're competing against a product
that compounds management fees over time
you can see we have an inherited vancha
but the other reason is a lot of what we
do is we take
sips and rather put generic defense
industry today this motif is built on
high ROI warfare even in a world where
we're cutting defense spending we're
moving to higher ROI weaponry and so
there's just a different way to go
invest here if you said you had a
different perspective on this you could
click customize and all of a sudden you
see these sliders pop up I can take down
command and control today you stop at
zero when you move into a move the
slider to the left pretty soon it'll
move into negative territory later on
this year so you can actually go long
short just by moving these sliders
unlike a fund you purchase direct
ownership in these securities and you
click purchase and all of a sudden
you've bought two hundred and fifty
dollars of this motif and you're all
ready to go we are the world's first
investing platform made social and if
you click on what others think we tell
you what other people think about this
motif you can see 89% bought the motif
as is eleven percent customized it and
one of the things we'll do later on this
year is will show you with permission
the people customizing people tend to
customize things they understand and as
we aggregate all this data you can pick
a trend on anything we have an Obamacare
motif for example and we can tell you
what everybody's thinking about a Matt
Bomer care at a very detailed segment
Elliott ation level we can tell you what
rich people poor people think young
people old and we're using this data to
help us better understand the world we
live in the day after Hurricane sandy we
launched a real building after sandy
motif not to make money but simply to
allow us to track what was going on in
the world around us so this is a new way
to think about investing and there are
lots of ideas and as I mentioned it took
us a long time to build these motifs we
have these professional investors who
have actually built these products but
our community is very passionate and
they built a whole whole universe of
motifs many of which are doing really
well and what's magical about this is
you'll see people with no background and
investing building amazing product and
these are there actual returns these are
not back tested these are motifs that
our communities are building and so it's
a very very different way
to think about investing